he wants a draw wait what I'm not gonna
take a draw I'm also not gonna watch his
stream I'm kind of nervous it's fine a
while since I played them I think that's
a free pawn but my hand is like shaking
this is so difficult I can take a night
right sick that night yeah I'm so slow
why am I so slow this is so difficult
okay me speed up oh shoot that's so good
oh that's so bad okay how do I resign
okay rematch I'm trying I've never
beaten a Kimora in one minute though so
if I win a game it's gonna be huge this
is a good position I think he's winning
the bishop by Windu's bishop mmm let's
do this no stop it okay resign I mean I
got a good position but that's difficult
is he not gonna accept again I'm just
I'm too bad for him
oh he accepted okay let's play the same
line because I like this
efore move and we're gonna go is the
same thing this time he plays Knight c3
which probably more playable let's trade
everything I'm okay with trading
everything and now we're gonna play some
some position where hopefully I won't
plunder
his Knights tricky
Knights are better than everything in
bully mmm let's take a five I can take I
mean I'm not down anything yet a four is
probably a decent move and then push up
c4 and then something like c6 movie
that's attacking me this is draw ish but
maybe not I'm so slow that's the problem
that was stopped playing good moose mmm
I got counter play rook c3 he doesn't
allow it
maybe g3 wow I tried to trick him okay
good game how I resigned I don't usually
stream on chess comm so this is new for
me but we're gonna play this opening
with h4 and then each five I think is
playable
maybe f4 this looks like a fun line g3
solid D 5 a 4
keep pushing pawns okay okay and do that
do this I mean I'm getting reasonable
positions I think he's just so good at
chess
what are these moves also good move
let's do that I'm night afore I guess
Maya for actually might be good I'm up a
piece but this is still difficult
he has comp he's threatening b2 but I
can take it I think he missed that
because I defend I'm defending things
kind of what does that move his Queens
attacked let's do that
no he's gonna fork me in the end and I'm
flagging no you see if I can stalemate
myself
never mind he's so good I felt like I
had like a good position but ok let me
up the pace I'll play a six trick teens
and he keeps doing this stuff where he
has knights and bishops should
inherently be better but I don't know
it's tricky c5 is a good move I think
and b5 maybe a pawn storm c4
I think open files are more valuable
than pawns okay we want to keep all
their works on the board let's play h5
then you were gay for I guess oh you
didn't ponder that
I don't want to trade rooks though I
might have to we're getting keen power
I'm down to pawns but mmm is there
counter play I want to meet him on b1
that would be nice but I have to do that
let's run to h2 and try and take the
pawn let's do this move first he's
stopping us and I'm so slow like why is
he so fast I don't know if he should
have allowed that well that was a good
move though
okay good game that was actually higher
quality I think it's hard to beat him
let's play h5 and then that this is
already like a really good position I'm
still probably gonna lose but at least I
have some hope let's do that and this is
painful like I don't know what to do
my mind doesn't work as fast as his
let's do that yes let's do this
a5 this is so complicated but if I got
the initiative it's good for me I think
do I want a castle I guess it's risky
but sometimes that's what you have to do
in life let's do that and that's always
flaking b1 you King King a1 was a
terrible move oh my gosh
cuz he choose now hanging how do I break
through and there's literally like no
break through unless there is it's just
sack stuff and hope it works
and take on g5
mmm oh he didn't blunder anything
there's one check it didn't work though
damn dang this is stressful like playing
like one of the best bullet players in
the world let's stick with what I know
is I've been getting like I think decent
positions mm what do I do here did I
take okay had to take and we just
developed normally put the bishop back
keep the pin mm queenside castle I mean
I think I'm getting very reasonable
positions I think this is already
Pleasant for for black I think and he's
streaming to the more people are
watching history I do anything here
coming g5 this is actually a decent game
so far let's try not to mess it up let's
take this should be a draw if I don't
flag let's do that let's put the Queen
on e4 if he puts me man he's gonna flag
me okay
this is painful this is really painful
uh man good game because he's so fast
like what do I do
he keeps gaining the one rating point or
playing grand-prix attack except working
close sicilian as he played a 6 b 5 and
we're playing at 5 I have some attack
here
I just have to like build my confidence
it's playing something like someone like
him it's uh
it's tough to lose so many games in a
row but again I like my position I think
this is easier to play h4 will take
doing some free moving I do have to
watch the clock my king will be
happening on g3 I think put the rook on
the H file uh between c4 check is a good
move I think and then oh no I lost a
queen that's so bad can I take it any
tricks with a check if one check and
then 96 yeah I resign and I'm getting
good positions it's just he's about to
adopt me he's already won eight games
let's play normal chess a six is a pet
line or I just wanna do stuff like
typical Queens gambit declined seems
like he knows what he's doing
what is d5 I was a weird move just gave
me like a free pawn again like a good
position I just have to stay calm and
not plunder oh that was a good move he
takes air I'm still up upon though
except probably not for long I just have
to keep trading stuff let's play d5 and
then maybe Queen here uh he didn't hang
the rook mmm
well put the rook on G eggs if he lets
me please let me I'm attacking his rook
so he can't take the knight
we're gonna still try to play with th
and that H for mmm I feel like he's out
playing me though I got kind of stuck
now no that was a really important pawn
it just lost uh I'm still trying we have
some tricky check oh there's nothing to
play that I'm defending I think just
kidding okay I've lost nine in a row
if he wins another one it's known as
adoption which is not preferable but I'm
gonna fight when you try and play
quicker than normal pretty sure I can
take and then I'm Bishop f2 and g4 that
was a good move I was also a good move
stop playing good moves because now I
can't like I can't queenside castle with
this bishop like a play g5 and then as
bishop still strong man he keeps
uncorking like these amazing moves
okay we're castling i just kept to his
attack but i don't know it's equal
material at least uh he takes their
weight I'd lost a rook what okay man
it's so sad he just beat me ten in a row
I thought I had good positions but he
just kept beating me okay I might end
the stream there that was fun let's go
to his stream oh I hope people were able
to see that
ah the board may have been misaligned oh
I don't want to go there let's just go
to my go to his stream like chess comm /
TV
well that was sad okay yeah I'm ending
the stream there whoever was watching
that I don't there was anyone watching
um
because I just didn't promote it at all
but I hope people enjoy that I'll be
back in the future maybe with some more
oh wait I'm playing him again what okay
we're continuing now the board should be
fixed so hopefully it's looking okay and
we're playing the same line which what
is going on here Bishop g3 is a move
that's annoying Queen d6 maybe I have no
time to think am I taking for what is
this this should be good for black right
oh my gosh I'm so confused okay we're
gonna try and Castle queenside and
attack him or not I have no moves here I
could play King g7 King CH and then this
is ugly ah let's do that is there
anything with the checks one check man
he's so good I don't know what he was
doing there um he's beating me 12 games
in the row let's play a four go he
played b5 let's play e5
okay I'm crushing him this this opening
the problem is he's still gonna beat me
something wrong okay we'll take know
this is actually playable keep trading
stuff I don't think he has Queen a1 he
might have Queen anyone that's why he
was thinking there but we'll just try
and keep everything defended maybe
throwing east six I think he six is a
playable move and my Chi five I have
access to f7 my let's defend each other
he made this he made Smee on G - oh I
thought everything was covered that game
I guess not
everyone's playing a five these days
which I don't understand
shoot I just hung a rook this is so
difficult
okay we're gonna play London let this
move order and then each five again and
we sack and I think objectively black
should be better but it should be easier
for white to play because I have more
minor pieces but he is Nakamura mmm I'll
do that
yeah okay do I hang anything I don't
know or we're just trading everything
can I take they're probably not and he
wins f2 oh my gosh this is so painful uh
okay we're gonna play the same line and
now I feel warmed up I feel like I can
give him I forgot to play e4 okay
well we're gonna keep fighting and I'm
gonna stop talking because it's really
difficult to talk and play Nakamura h5h
4G 5g for just throw all the pieces of
him don't play Queen a7 okay
five that was a good move can be eight
okay this is embarrassing
I didn't realize losing to him could be
so embarrassing but it is it's trade
bishops take I'm just slow I'm using a
trackpad what else can I do I might see
one typical move it's like a Nigel short
move can we do this this is actually
very similar to the game short Hossein
except f5s probably an improvement as
this work that works right now wins a
piece no it doesn't or does it I take
I'm so confused and there's no time to
calculate I can play a four I think but
he's up so much time that's the problem
but I might like this is my best
position I've had so far I think except
nevermind oh man I just hung a queen
what is that it's a problem when I get
good positions I just freak out okay uh
he 5e for this time okay remember my
openings and we're taking we'll play
Bishop here and let's throw in the
Bishop c5 check and I don't think he can
play t4 he plays easy five okay
I'll bring the bishop back I don't know
if I should should have Castle kingside
be just like 93 which is nice on a good
day I can win this but it's not been a
great day so far it's a knife f5 man ok
I have to do this oh my gosh 97 I keep
hanging my queen ahh
ok he's beating me 17 games in a row
let's play the English like maybe I
could trick him somehow I even know what
I'm saying anymore
let's castle at some points before and
we'll play Knight
we can't play Knight c5 ok so now it's
just positional f5 happens he's just
crushing me what to do
[Music]
ok the exchange isn't the end of the
world
I have tactics against his rook maybe
let's put the bishop on c6 he just trap
my queen
let's order mmm man ok I feel like a
punching bag right now before I need
some improvement at this line maybe here
and then I can take oh this should be
good
let's see 95 Queen h4 maybe play bit
more ambitiously I'm still playing
slowly that's the problem
Queen is nice on h6 aisle Castle
queenside and I'll try it to attack at
6:00 let's do that thanks for the follow
distant fire I'm not looking at the chat
so I don't know if people are
communicating but I do see the follows
g6 I have to open files on the kingside
mmm g8 I can take right
maybe g5 g5 + h5 at some point d4 could
happen he wants to fork me again I
learned my lesson from last game sort of
I'm flagging so badly though and my
Queen's trapped how did that happen my
Queen's trapped in the center of the
board okay he's won 19 in a row he's
going for the double adoption just kind
of sad but that's life let's play like
Karpov like slow steady solid chess
except my chief 4 is kind of painful
I don't think Karpov would be too
impressed with this Queens he Ford
thanks for the follow stop you something
let's do this and that and that this is
actually a decent position because e6 is
weak and maybe I can do something do I
can take his rook attack the Queen I
think and maybe I can stop the double
adoption efore hangs it's getting a
little bit messy let's do that and this
I'm still playing slowly but I'm out to
exchange let's get the rook into
somewhere more useful mmm
before I think that works cuz rookie
seven happens if he takes on c3 this is
completely winning but it's
nerve-racking at 15 seconds mmm and he's
running away stop no g4 oh my gosh
what's going on no I didn't mean to play
Queen g2 oh okay
oh he just beat me 20 games in a row
that was really close so um I just got
like my fingers got sweaty playing with
the trackpad like what what else can I
do
well that was fun uh I don't know if
he's gonna play again let me fix this
just a little bit
he was also streaming that I'm sure he
had fun just like kicking me around I
will go to the chat let's see if this
attracted anyone I think he just
declined the challenge whatever that
sound was as a sound of rejection that's
sad
well I'll probably put that on YouTube